In this lesson, we'll use Microsoft's
HealthVault, but there are several
widely used personal health records,
and they mostly do the same things.
You should already have a HealthVault
account, but we haven't yet
explored it to see how it
stores clinical data and
what it can do to help patients use that
data, including sharing it with others.
So here's an example of my health
data I manually input in HealthVault.
You can see key data such
as patient allergies,
immunizations, conditions,
and lab test results.
As shown here, users are assisted in
inputting complex information such as
their condition by smart lists
that pop up as they type.
More recently, as meaningful
use has dictated the export
of at least standardized
clinical summaries,
the burden on the patient to record
all their data is largely alleviated.
And the PHR can and
should import these summaries from all
providers caring for that patient.
Note here that I have a direct email
address provided to me by HealthVault
to help facilitate that.